what is one of your favorite opening
works of fiction well what I did was I
brought the openings of three works of
fiction and I'm going to show you sort
of different ways that a story can begin
and and be effective the first opening
is from the Mona Simpson story Lawns it
was published in I believe First in 1984
in the Iowa review and then it was
reprinted in best American short stories
in 1986
and in this opening we have access to
the narrator's thoughts and the
narrator's thoughts are important she is
speaking to the reader we're getting
some kind of psychological portrait of
her we're learning about the condition
that she is generally in at the moment
so here's the opening
I steal
I've stolen books and money and even
letters letters are great I can't tell
you the feeling walking down the street
with twenty dollars in my purse stolen
earrings in my pocket I don't get caught
that's the amazing thing you're out on
the sidewalk other people all around
shopping walking and you've got it
you're out of the store you've done this
thing you're not supposed to do but no
one stops you
at first it's like a rush it's like
you're even for everything you didn't
get before but then you're left alone no
one even notices you nothing changes
so here is sort of introducing a
character the interior of a character
and then some kind of problem that she's
facing which is she's doing something
that is dangerous and transgressive and
she knows on some level that it's wrong
but she is motivated as you sort of see
by the way she thinks
um and so we as the reader are beginning
to think well what's going to happen to
her is she going to keep stealing is are
things going to get worse
um you know we we take what she's saying
almost to be a confession and so this
kind of
this kind of access to a character's
inner life is one of is a very it can be
a great way to start a short story
um here's a different short story this
is from The Killers by Ernest Hemingway
and I'm just going to read you
um the first two sentences but here we
don't have any access to the characters
thoughts at all everything is external
so it's almost as if there's a camera
that's looking down on the scene and
presenting information to the reader so
this you know it's a very simple two
sentences
but as with as is usually the case with
Hemingway you know he he only gives you
a limited amount of description but what
he gives you is usually significant so
the the story starts off with 17 simple
words the door of Henry's lunchroom
opened and two men came in they sat down
at the counter
that's dramatized action that is putting
a story into motion through what people
do so you have Henry's lunchroom it's
named it's not just a lunchroom it's
Henry's lunchroom it opens and two men
come in two men are described as
strangers it's not Joe and Jim didn't
come in it's two men came in so you have
a specific lunchroom and then you have
General visitors and then they sat down
at the counter means something is going
to happen with the presentation of
um you know something's going to happen
over lunch and that's what that's what
does happen and Hemingway after a few
lines of dialogue goes on to describe
one of the men
he says he wore a derby hat and a black
overcoat buttoned across the chest his
face was small and white and he had
tight lips
he wore a silk Muffler and gloves
well who sits down for to eat something
at five in the afternoon wearing a hat
wearing a buttoned overcoat and wearing
a muffler and gloves
the story is called The Killers so the
the writer Hemingway is getting us
to ask questions are these The Killers
if so who are they there to kill what's
their motivation for being there who
sent them
like again a a strong opening
um
sort of persuades the reader that it
would be in the reader's best interest
to keep reading because you'll be paid
off nicely for it
do we have time to do one more oh yes
please okay absolutely okay absolutely
so the last story that I would like to
sort of show the opening of
is a story that begins with dialogue so
you have inner thought for the first
opening you have dramatic action for the
second opening and you have dialogue for
the third opening so this is Lori
Moore's story face time it was published
in the New Yorker a couple years ago and
it was reprinted in the 2022 Oh Henry
prize stories which is what I'm reading
from at the moment
I asked my father if he knew where he
was and he said kind of
you are in the hospital your hip surgery
went well but there is a virus and you
have been found to have it you are
contagious no one can get near
it's happening all over the world you
caught it in your assisted living
facility the chef had it
entirely through dialogue except for the
first few words of the first sentence so
we're just being given a lot of clear
information you were asking earlier can
the reader sort of can the writer overdo
it with description at the beginning too
many names too many facts too much
information yes and so what she does
here is she slows it down with short
sentences and she sort of
you know gives us the conditions that
this story
is beginning with I mean I asked my
father if he knew where he was just that
alone is a very it provokes thought it
even provokes sympathy because if it if
he's demented
we're going to start feeling both for
him and for her and then the answer to
the question is kind of well what does
that mean do you kind of know where you
are like to what extent do you know
where you are and to what extent do you
not and so the daughter says you are in
the hospital
well if you have to tell someone that
he's in a hospital that tells you a lot
about the you know mental condition that
that the person is your hip surgery went
well this tells you that the person is
older well not necessarily but it's
usually older people who have hip
fractures and require hip surgery
so again Laurie Moore is not explaining
all this she's showing it through you
know good use of dialogue but there is a
a virus and you have been found to have
it
well you know all of us who live through
this period know exactly what virus
we're talking about and and the kind of
circumstances
um that the father would be in you are
contagious no one can get near so here
you are in the hospital you can't go to
the place you're living because you
caught the virus there and now you can't
go back
um you're gonna have to wait until you
get a negative
um it's happening all over the world so
the father doesn't understand what's
going on with him personally nor does he
understand what's going on in the world
that at large and I mean this story is
is sort of
it's it's really delivering painful
truths about what it's like to
be in contact with a loved one a dear
loved one during a time of com his
compromised mental activity and again
the writer is not explaining it
the writer is just using dialogue to
show what's going on
short sentences and it seems like two
not overly long overly flowery flowery
wording and it really helps you kind of
dig into what's going on because you're
not sure you're like following it along
but it's not it's it's do you notice
that with with newer writers that they
tend to use sort of big words and it
takes you out of the story sometimes you
do see that like unnecessarily big words
or unnecessarily flowery language don't
don't get me wrong though I do love many
writers who write not in this way and
it's I mean Lori Moore writes all kinds
of sentences of all kinds of lengths and
rhythms and sounds and so on I I was
just saying like as a way of introducing
information if you sort of do it in
short sentences where first of all the
reader can digest what's going on but
also the father might only be able to
understand a few words at a time so
she's almost explaining it so that
someone who's as mentally compromised as
he is might be under might be able to
understand it as well